contra todo pronóstico la esperanza de
una primera vacuna francesa contra el
hobbit no vendrá de un gigante
farmaceútico sino de una pequeña empresa
y los suburbios de nantes de valnera un
laboratorio franco austriaco
especializado en biotecnología ha optado
por basar su vacuna candidata en una
tecnología idéntica a la de la vacuna
contra la gripe y los resultados
preliminares de los ensayos clínicos son
alentadores y muy pronto se decidió
desarrollar una vacuna inactivada que
complementará las otras tecnologías
desarrolladas midiendo de la rl
mensajero a vacunas vivas y las vacunas
de vectores virales la razón por la que
decidimos hacer esto es porque la vacuna
inactivada es una vacuna muy conocida
que se sabe que se busca que se puede
administrar en los niños los ancianos a
las mujeres embarazadas y a las personas
inmunodeprimidas nos pareció interesante
pero las primeras dosis no se entregarán
a francia ni tampoco a europa sino a
reino unido- el primero en creer en el
proyecto
el reino unido se interesó por nuestra
vacuna porque creía en nuestra vacuna
inactivada y teníamos una instalación
existente en escocia así que nos
presentaron una propuesta de
financiación muy rápidamente lo que
falta no sólo en francia sino en europa
son fondos suficientemente dotados
grandes fondos de inversión dedicados a
la salud y que sean capaces de hacer
apuestas de asumir riesgos como este
para financiar la fase final con el
objetivo de que las empresas
biotecnológicas puedan llevar a cabo
todo el proceso comercializar sus
productos y seguir siendo independientes
hasta el final
una situación que empuja a algunos de
los aspirantes a abandonar el país es el
caso del francés stéphane van zyl al
frente de moderna pero no sólo las
empresas jóvenes se ven afectadas los
gigantes de la industria farmacéutica
también miran al exterior quisieron que
el sector de la salud pagará una parte
disparatada del déficit anual de la
seguridad social por eso obligaron a las
empresas a conseguir soluciones
económicas para producir sus
medicamentos y encuentran la solución en
algunos países europeos en irlanda
escocia o fuera de europa en india donde
se fabrican productos cuyos precios aquí
han sido tan bajos que los laboratorios
se ven abocados a elegir estas
soluciones si dejan que los cerebros se
vayan dejan que los conocimientos
industriales se vayan eso es obviamente
algo terrible
sin embargo como se explica la derrota
del instituto pasteur y del gigante de
sanofi en francia en enero de 2021 paseo
a abandonar su proyecto de vacuna basado
en el vector del sarampión para el
organismo de investigación es
principalmente el resultado de la mala
suerte hay toda una serie de tecnologías
que merecen ser evaluadas en una
situación de pandemia alguna funcionarán
y otras no quizás el diseño que hicimos
del antígeno no es el mismo que se ha
hecho en otras situaciones y tal vez por
eso no es el diseño adecuado pero no lo
sé
y más allá de las malas elecciones pase
ojo no dispone de las líneas de
producción imprescindibles para realizar
los ensayos clínicos tardó seis meses en
firmar una asociación con marc y
comenzar por fin el proceso de
investigación frente a competidores
mucho más reactivos podemos preguntarnos
por qué moderna empezó sus ensayos
clínicos en marzo de 2020 porque oxford
empezó en abril y nosotros en agosto
así por ejemplo 8 for tiene una
infraestructura de producción y por eso
no dependen necesariamente de un
proveedor
y les ahorra tiempo
sanofi aún no ha perdido la esperanza de
una vacuna
el pasado mes de mayo el grupo creó una
controversia
el grupo recibe un cheque de casi dos
mil quinientos millones de dólares de la
agencia federal estadounidense para
llevar a cabo sus investigaciones y
anunciar que suministrará sus vacunas de
forma prioritaria en eeuu
tras un fracaso inicial el pasado
diciembre el gigante francés anunció que
había reanudado los ensayos clínicos de
fase 2 para este vídeo logo francia
sigue en la carrera
la carrera por la vacuna no ha terminado
porque hay dos cuestiones importantes la
primera es garantizar la inmunización
mundial por lo que vamos a tener que
abordar los problemas de la compra de
vacunas para los países que actualmente
no tienen los medios además de los
problemas logísticos asociados a ello la
segunda cuestión es que como vemos hoy
en día pueden surgir variantes así que
vamos a tener que desarrollar las nuevas
vacunas que se adapten a la aparición de
variantes que pueden causar problemas de
escape de la vacuna pzifer variante que
es transgénica vall nueva y todos los
demás aseguran que podrán adaptar sus
vacunas a las mutaciones del virus
insinuando que existirá una multitud de
vacunas en el mercado a pesar de la
urgencia la carrera de las vacunas es
más una maratón que un sprint